no [ __ ] i'm still looking for a headset
i found one though i found one i found
one
hurry up it's been an hour sorry it has
not been an hour
you were driving home when we started
this process oh you're already you're
picking a character okay yeah get with
it so you said you're going bandit
[ __ ] yeah always every time every single
time i'm just gonna be a bandit with you
because i've just never done that i
actually bandits
you don't recommend this build
[ __ ] no absolutely not oh this this is
if you hate yourself like me do you hate
yourself so you try to make the game as
hard as possible on yourself right
okay
yeah i just noticed this character
starting level is five
you know what i've never done it let's
do it like i'll just i'll be i'll be the
same all right i don't know if you're
recording yet but no i am
everybody watching this jake's about to
get hard-carried
i'm gonna get carried okay
you're the one that has 400 hours but
i'm going to be carrying you through at
least like you haven't even beaten the
game yet i don't have to beat the game
all right how do i want to do my hair
this is the girliest i've ever been in
my life i just want to stop
do i want to updo do i want to undercut
no okay i'm spending an hour of this if
you could stop bitching that would be
i'm just spinning my guy in a circle
all right seamless co-op play host use
the tiny great pot to create a party
other players may join by using the
effigy of melania where's the pot dog
separating this you gotta take a picture
let me get out of here yeah i'm gonna
take i'm gonna take a piss on you to
separate
where's the pot where's the pot where's
the pot
are you a narc jacob no
it's i see it it's in your inventory
tiny great wait oh it's in your
inventory i was running around
you're actually oh opens your world to
wanderers okay where do you want me to
put it open the world to wanderers
all right
i'm glowing i glowed yep i'm glowing
okay okay i'm joining i'm wandering oh
oh oh hold on hold on did you figure it
out heading password setting password
okay okay on me on me coming on me
okay
good okay do you remember sorry go ahead
one
september um i'm already in a party
so
smile using music your world is now open
to new wanderers
failed you must set a session password
i'm going to i'm going to end it
oh i wonder if we both have to use the
pot
that would make sense
okay because it's our same world
oh
like duh yeah okay you keep your pot on
it says failed you must say right again
i am i keep trying it it keeps saying
failed i don't understand what it means
by set a session possibly what does that
mean i don't know because we did that
already i thought i know that's why i
was trying to see it by the co-op
password thing but it's in there
[Applause]
oh my god
oh my god
a little off let's try that again one
two three go yeah yeah okay
one two three go
oh my god discord one
two three go
nice let's go oh yeah you're just legit
sitting there can you see me walking
around i can that's kind of wicked it's
kind of can we sit together
yeah sit sit down
oh my god
this is cute
candle at dinner smile yep with bones of
people nice all right let's get the [ __ ]
out of here so if you hit this do we
both have it now
like if i check my map yeah
that's really cool like we could go off
on our own if we wanted and go get our
own sites of grace i would ever do that
here i don't know hey
oh my god the bandit attacks so fast
yeah bro nice but dad did you see how
[ __ ] little damage you do
yeah 24 damage why did you pick this
because i played this game on hard mode
yeah i see you up there
too early he has eye frames my guy come
on
guy digging
digging for that ass
oh he's getting up
i need to oh [ __ ] because i got them in
iframes
as i'm hitting them i frames why is this
guy so strong holy [ __ ] what up rick
all right i'm honestly just gonna sit
here it's pickle rick i'm gonna try and
parry him
good luck
i missed
oh
oh my god
all right maddie do you want to finish
this
finish them off
in this
give me your cummies
sorry okay let's go what what was that
nothing nothing please let's go okay
we can kill him because we technically
can't do his quest line would you would
you look at his blood on the rock by the
way a little bit he's really hard by the
way so we're gonna have to work together
on this
don't be a [ __ ] jacob we don't even
have torrent yet don't be a [ __ ] come
here you fat [ __ ] this is actually
probably going to be hard yeah
i'm not scared i'm hitting him for 18
18.
this is great
he's kind of scary looking though can
you help
oh
we can we can do it
never mind
running away from me
oh stop it oh god
i have no more flash i'm just saying
this
okay
oh fatty
oh i died too
[Laughter]
are you not right next to me right now
no
what are you slapping i don't know
what's happening but you are just you're
in the ground right next
look at it
you see me
see what i'm doing
you see what's happening
yes i see you're standing in fire
heating up your uh heating up your uh
dinner oh my god all right
i like your steak cooked jake why did we
pick this bandit class it feels terrible
i told you not to do it i got this
take him out
take him out 25. 25
wait i feel like we really should not
have picked this class but we'll figure
it out we're fine we're fine i told you
you triggered the cutscene
oh sorry
it's just you in the cutscene
get wrecked she's next to me sit down
sit down he's not here okay i'm sitting
the melano
now she's to my right whoa she came in
fast have you heard of the thing that's
what she said she she she she said but
you i'm afraid are maidenless and now
i'm crying what are you talking about
why are you yelling at me stop
okay cool so we literally have two
torrents this is actually really cool
look at the rat boy
what'd you go and do that for
what's up rat boy can we even beat this
guy i have no idea yes
if we can't beat the tree sentinel
just be good forehead
oh my god i'm dead
that's a good idea arrows
i missed
some rants oh [ __ ]
did you die yeah i got [ __ ] up
dude nothing's loading for me oh i see
it
i can't i can't see
how do i get back oh
rot essence hopelessness
what did i just get you want to go beat
up bloodhound
yeah
i really want to use this this sword
actually so
we should do this where is he at where's
he at over here okay beat him up beat
him up beat him up
okay hold on i gotta remember his moves
we also could have had glide come help
us
okay why did we pick this character do
you want to report no i don't want to
restart are you sure
i it just has no help with the worst
weapon in the game okay i spawned down
the hill i'm coming the boss is just
gone
the boss is gone
where yeah okay i'm coming hold on
god i died two hits he's kind of
freaking out right now
oh yeah
little bleed little bleed
no
oh i got it
you're doing so good he might disappear
though metal babe has fallen he didn't
disappear for you nah what the [ __ ]
he was just not there for me
i'm gonna finish this for us
[ __ ] delay
no
i don't want to throw
no no
i'm throwing
intake
i love doing 18 damage metal
i could not tell you to pick this glass
you did you kinda did by picking the
class youtube
already gone the footage is gone no it's
not
it's gone i said do whatever you want
you see my horse
yes
i beat the dragon like this just like
yeah
you want to try yeah we could try i'm
good okay that's a lot of runes i think
how the [ __ ] did you beat the dragon
doing this little damage i
hate myself and this is how i played
dark souls 1.
damn
okay hang left nice
uh
his beat his ankles at back here
that's what i'm doing
i jumped on his face
i'm so incredibly dead i got stuck on a
crab maddie dead i actually got stuck on
a crab i think because you diet ends the
boss fight for me no we're too far away
he's appearing and reappearing for me
yeah he's doing the same thing
i have no doubt you could beat the
dragon but uh
it might take half an hour
yeah we don't want to do that
okay
i don't know what's going on but the
spectating's really
[Laughter]
going down in an endless void underneath
the planet
thanks for waiting
yeah of course
as you take the elevator down without me
i'm not taking the elevator [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
oh i died
i'm so mad at you
i said are you just stunned that this is
how i played the game i
like i understand why you haven't beaten
the game yet
alright this is a bad idea hit it
okay we're gonna jump right here right
here
god damn it god damn it
just jump jump
we got this i have no health no flash
let's just do this thing he's big
oh my god this [ __ ] weapon can't even
hit him okay you can if you hit the
right part of the foot
ow
yep
there it is
nice dodging good bleed
oh holy [ __ ]
that looks really bad on my screen
like that just look like you got [ __ ]
you're like a baseball
yep absolutely bonked
oh you died right in front of me
you're not even
yeah you look really cool right now
you're you're just gliding for me okay
who needs who needs to run
not you apparently
oh god now i'm dead
metal
don't worry all the wasted time
bad thing
cause every little thing that is gonna
be all right did i make it hello you're
not dead
how are you get them tankles maddie get
them cakes
oh look at how look out these are big
i'm not scared of him he looks like i am
he looks like a punk oh big swing big
swing
oh he pulls it back out bro pull out
game strong
pull out game
bro those come out so fast
i gotta run
that [ __ ] killed me okay even though
i'm that far away you can do it maddie
skate right
yeah the skating is just so funny to me
okay
you almost got him
oh
it's a little damaged a little damage no
problem
that's fine
it's fade on over
oh close close close
this giant attacks very fast i died i
saw
i do see that
[ __ ] my butt
there's no [ __ ] way
please keep stomping on me daddy i love
it
thanks
keep it going i love it i guess
god damn i've
stepped on you
okay one more time oh my god
that's attractive
[Music]
i got slapped in the face
sick
maddie why do you pick this class it's
so awful
hey jake hey
oh i forgot we had to jump
man oh no
do i even continue this
yes
what immaculate timing thank you
thank you for that
why did that hit me dude
i can't even see
thank you
it's like you're an ant down
i'm making the decision metal we restart
we restart tomorrow with a completely
different build because this is
ridiculous
this is just absolutely ridiculous that
two of us can't beat the trolls
what i have a question what is your
question i'm on my knees begging begging
can i can i can i be the bandit still
smiling no you can still be a bandit i'm
not i
am not subjecting myself to this
i
love suffering so much this is the class
that i've played most of this [ __ ]
game with jacob everything i stab it
tickles them and they they look at me
and they go
metal babe that was so [ __ ] funny and
they do that
until i murder them but you can do
whatever you want
oh okay we didn't make any progression
that's fine but
we learned something
landscapes down here
[Music]
you